this is one of my favorite subject of
all JavaScript is like as Guillermo say
before like JavaScript can be be on the
web you can do a lot of amazing things
with JavaScript not only on the website
but you can dollar theme especially on
the hardware side so I'm gonna to talk
today about the JavaScript oryx or so I
talked about note boats
Sanna chips we're talking about this
topic in her talk so I'm gonna like to
pass through some topics that are really
similar the the idea is like to show the
the stuff I bring here some of my
experiments or products that I've been
working on and I want to share it with
you so no boats basically is robotics
that are made accessible to JavaScript
developers this is possible right now
because of nodejs
but the main idea the main philosophy of
notebooks is that can be used with
different JavaScript platforms right now
the main platform is Bay news is no but
maybe in the future there would be other
JavaScript reforms that would be in able
to control hardware or electronics or
robot say using javascript so this is
torold by chris williams or buddha Tiki
God he is the main organizer of the J's
comp in United States and he wrote like
library called notes Edo port that will
enable you to control CEO the Harvard
devices used in JavaScript so this is
using like a native simples flows being
the in order to do the communication but
this will enable to you not only to
control like a development board like an
Arduino but some other different
hardware projects as you can see today
so basically this started using the
notes field port the module and the film
at a Fermata is a framework needs to be
a blow to they Arduino to the board and
this will enable like a serial API so
you will control the board you
like a serial API communication and you
can do like most of the things that an
Adreno or a board can do so initially
this these were like the start like
using a sweet important from our above
this has been a ball the ball being
really fast so let's introduce you to
Johnny 525 is a library created by Rick
Waldron Rick Warren is my really really
smart guy and I really admire him and if
I'll also be behind this is like you can
write hard work code as easy as you are
writing like web applications similar
like the philosophy to jQuery when you
are like years in evidence and you are
controlling the different Dom elements
but they've an idea that you can control
hardware devices using plain simple
JavaScript so an example here it's basic
code where you need to install from NPM
the journey 5 library it will fetch the
library and son it in your computer and
you are like only with a few lines of
code creating like abort
so you are controlling the board you are
you want to work with and when the board
is ready you are instantiating of
creating a new instance of the class let
and then you are executing methods on
that object so this is the basic code to
make a web blink so this with this basic
code you you are going to see like a LED
linking if you if you want to like to
write this same piece of code on Arduino
using the wiring or C++ you need like to
define to define delays on first turn on
the LED then turn off the LED and
control the timing using 25 is as easy
as as you can see on the on the screen
there are different abstractions on
journey 5 there is like a huge list of
abstraction taken from the universal
source code it is really really good
this structure if you want like to
contribute cool open source project dial
and by the
to contribute the 25 my first like
pooled request to open-source project
was with 25 I was a note note conf 2015
and I wanted to play with the PSO class
I say okay I can like make sound with a
little specific electronic circuit but
the class wasn't implemented at the time
so I asked free
oh-hoh kind of play with this PSO and he
said it's not implemented please do it
so I took that as a challenge it took me
like one year to to complete the pull
request but I created like the basic
implementation of the PS class and now
you can like play sounds using in
Journey five and demonstrate though
there are different other abstractions
for connecting sir ball sensors
radio infrared the electronic system so
they're pretty free very young there are
other other frameworks that will enable
you to control hardware and the result
are called silent ASAP is quite
different but it can support like a
different type of boards so this is a
right now initially we started like with
Arduino but right now the echo system of
boards off electronic boards has been
growing so we have now a dream of
Raspberry Pi BeagleBone black Pinocchio
spark
Galileo tehsil a lot of boards that can
be controlled using javascript there
even once one board that can be
controlled directly with JavaScript not
using like a serial connection as we are
doing with adreno but internally in the
microcontroller they are doing some
interesting stuff as tehsil there's a
loose a cool company that I was creating
a board that can be programmed directly
with JavaScript so javascript is taking
the hardware part but for me the more
important part of no BOTS is not like
the hardware or the things you can do
with it school you can do a lot of
interesting projects but for me the most
interesting part of no BOTS is the
community it's a really really big
community and really impressive
community and so welcoming I feel really
rebuilding
in this community in this note Kampf I
get my first Arduino kid as a gift from
Raquel Bayless rattle Bailey's he's one
of the robot-assisted are working on the
core project of no BOTS and she gave me
a kid and she said to me grab his kid
and teach the people in Colombia how to
use it and right now this was kind of
one year ago and right now we have like
a lot of kids that some people are
donating to the community I had the
opportunity to travel to other countries
and to start other communities there so
they held both community is really
powerful and empowering so there is the
International Notebook day it happens
once a year and community for from all
around the world gets together and play
with wave JavaScript and with no BOTS so
we are all around the world and we want
to see more dots or more communities in
Latin America because we want like to
spread the war and to have like a really
healthy community and there's no boats
también habla espanol although they also
speak Spanish there are really
interesting a community in Latin America
and we are starting with the ginger
years with about 100 people attended to
the first and no birthday we started
like basically learn learning how to
plug other chronic components to the
board and we right now we have like a
bigger community we were like giving
away hard work to other people in order
to pull them to keep working on hard war
and we have like from kids to six or
eight years old to the people well maybe
70 80 years so it's a really interesting
thing to to share with other people so I
had the opportunity to travel to
Guatemala to uh to give a workshop and a
talk about loud boats and in Guatemala
right now there are two no boats
community the main community it's on the
capital city and the other community is
really interesting it's located
really a small Mayan town that has a
really small population and people from
from this town travel to Guatemala City
like nine hours by using the boss and
and we give them a lot of hardware and
they are right now
managing that community there auntie Xin
electronics to other people so this is
important and poor you know there are
other communities you can see there we
have so much fun in Guatemala we have
like a soccer tournament with two robots
where we're playing football on the the
people we gave like the free hardware
they are like teaching to other people
how to how to build this stuff and also
we have this I wrote note rockets even
though it's really awesome so bringing
more people into tech to through the
power of the community that is main idea
we want to we want to bring more people
into tag into software development
through the power of the community the
community is really powerful if you are
here is because you are interested in
something and get together with other
people hack together their or their
community's human societies or in the
city you are living in places this is
really interesting we we have the
opportunity to travel to to a town in in
Colombia it's an afro-colombian town
really poor or forgetting by the by the
government but they are like really
empowered because they they are using
technology to teach others and they are
changing the whole mindset so this is
for me really really really nice to be
part of this so this is the basic
introduction let's do some some demos
and see if this is working its fingers
this is hard this is the first one this
is a assumable this is all the whole
project is open source so you can
download the CAD files and am praying
the the parts using a 3d printer or
Lassard Carter and we I'm using in this
project the SPARC microcontroller so the
spark is connected to Wi-Fi I'm going to
check if everything is working right now
so I'm going to plug it these will
connect to the SPARC cloud there is a
cloud the wheelers have this robot the
internet let's see is trying to connect
to the network okay it's connected and
I'm going to run the application
don't let me execute this
so my computer right now will add as a
web server so what we want is like to
control the the bot using the cell phone
or using a wearable let me check if the
application is working good I'm going
executed from here that's from the cell
phone if it's working and no nice
advanced
okay then they show really quick I
wanted like to execute it from the cell
phone but the connection is not working
right now but I can send comments to the
to the world I'm using the manual
version because I can oh thanks
nice catch
yeah well hey I wanted to control the
body isn't there the SmartWatch maybe
later the internet is not working right
now but well no problem this is the the
other project it's called a note copter
it's an AR Drone see if it's a novel
told a will told you this afternoon this
is like running our web server so I can
control this from a web application
grown in Express and socket IO now let
me see if I can control it so this has
like a Wi-Fi hotspot so I need to
connect to the Wi-Fi hotspot and do the
magic but it's not working
nice okay
ATM is working
meanwhile this is connected I can show
you other other projects this one eats
and gaita or queasy is like Colombian
fall instrument mainly used to play the
guy Tom yet to play cumbia anyone heard
cumbia anyone like cumbia cumbia Jetta
or gray that's good
so this is the this is like Ronnie now
webserver I'm using the bigger bone
black this has like a mic so each time I
told her the sensor noise he he will
like change the the color pouring but
they did like you can have your own
musical instrument and create a really
fun stuff so let me see if I can play it
okay
oops let's see if the other are working
in meanwhile Oh perfect
I think we are we aren't I'm so I'm not
a musician but I like some music
projects this is one I basic I've been
working on this is a drum kit so I'm
using like a pad like you can play some
sound
can I have audio I have a real great
thanks perfect thank you so we're doing
with these project is mapping the kids
their keys with with some samples from a
row on a real drum kit so you can build
your own instrument so let me play it
you're gonna execute it okay so you can
create me as he gave in with electronics
so now they're in the different oh okay
this this project this is connected
right now this is so unstable right now
because I crash it like up multiple
times
I'm not a good toilet but there can I
see the stream please can you focus the
screen or the video I need I want to
show okay so yeah let me check its first
application okay so I'm going to execute
the it's an application called the web
flight so you can control you can run
like an Express server and using Sicario
you will be able like to control an old
boat from your web browser so I'm going
to enter to express application okay
this is the camera of the drawing right
now this is the thing maybe it will
crash but I'm going to try to fly it so
say away whoa no no not the we know do
me no to me you know the way okay
whoa Lord and he doesn't like web
application just to know that it's
flying as you can see real time
really quickly we're gonna ask what it
is this is now that r2d2 hell and I
don't kill utterly do its have you heard
about an instrument called the Thurman
it's kind of a specie of termine let me
see it is working so why don't they need
this project is I'm going to run in the
studio I'm using like the right sensor
to control like the notes like the
frequency and the left sensor in there
are all transonic sensor so it measures
distance so I'm usually like to do to
control sound so can I see there okay
thank you let me mutant like a wood
application written by sub stuck
so I'm changing the frequency only using
the license
psycho plays on kind of music and then I
can add some really nice Distortion
so you can play with three different
experiences they'd be in a party or
something when you can use sensors and
culture the likes and as you can see the
the frequency of the sound is changing
this is all written in JavaScript so you
can create you
you're like music look like your music
function so it doesn't work
very good and the last one was the
clumsy pipette this one I have time to
play those we're done done okay so this
is a pipette did you use in aid servers
it seems that it would walk time times
over right okay it's sad okay okay
let's see I'm trying to teach him like
to walk but is not a really good Walker
so what I call it they like the clone
see the clown's here my pet so it has
like some problem walking but then I can
run really quickly here okay this is not
like he is trying to walk but there's
not a really good Walker so units teach
him oh it's residence so it's really
difficult to control like the age
servers at the same time the I'm using
like johnny-five in all of the
experiments it's a really powerful like
like library the someone won't want to
play with either later we are going to
stay here until December 10 and the main
idea is like to help with the local
community and to have some no box
experience here so we brought some
Arduino kit so the idea is like the next
week maybe we are going to to give up
workshop here and scenes
I received my first kid as a gift in an
event I want to give this like as a gift
for the community too so if you want to
keep this this robot in Argentina and
keep playing with it so I've been in
contact with with alejandro he is one of
the leaders of the note school community
in Buenos Aires
so alejandro if you are here this is for
you and this is for the community so
this is my multi-person tation and I
will invite you keep working together a
kid working community and please thank
you and welcome today's comfor along and
as you see you there
Alejandro flip it up if you're here let
me know and this is for the community